talking about the new Mission Impossible
trailer with my super-secret spy watch
that's so cool so the trailer for
Mission Impossible rogue nations hit the
internet and I was like I wouldn't a
Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol to see
the first five minutes of The Dark
Knight Rises walked out having seen one
of the best movies of the year so I
figure we talk about this but
Mission Impossible rogue nation Ethan
Hunt
learns that the rogue nation is real I
guess the rogue nation is a super secret
government organization designed to take
out super secret government
organizations like Ethan Hunt so that's
watching this trailer was like this does
feel a lot like a Bond movie
some people might be put off by that I'm
like well yeah I always saw a Mission
Impossible it's kind of like the
American James Bond it's gonna be better
than Skyfall probably not better than
Ghost Protocol probably not entertaining
hope so you see a lot of promise in this
trailer I mean all the action scenes
look cool really cool action among
a spy movie that's totally awesome to
have I hang up is the fact that directed
by a different director then goes
protocol now I'm talking about a call
like it's like the Jesus Christ of
Mission Impossible I think it kind of is
they came to save Mission Impossible
that direction was so good at doing
ghost Protocol now we have this new dude
who directed Jack Reacher barring a
couple of scenes in Jack Reacher that I
did enjoy it wasn't the hugest fan of
Jack Reacher he's made me back up and
like they see that simon Pegg's back
Ving Rhames is back Jeremy Renner I
think he's I think I saw him a lot of
fat stuff going on but I'm pretty sure I
saw runner but in my experience in
movies when you have a series in
different directors do the series and
it's not you know a Harry Potter where
they can't really go off the rails too
far every director wants to do with
different things the Ghost Protocol made
it was like ah this was sweet ensemble
and everyone in the team was cool I feel
like a new director can come on and be
like you know what wipe out everybody on
the team because we got to bring this
movie back down on cruise control I have
no evidence to show that he's actually
gonna do that I really doubt he's gonna
do that everything some trailers get me
really excited other trailers makes me
go hmm I'm excited but I want to be like
cautiously optimistic about this what's
the fact they bumped up the release date
from December to July that's a half a
year there's a lot of faith you have in
your movie or it's gonna be really
rushed but in a world where I have no
evidence to support my paranoia I'm
excited for this movie and that shot in
the trailer where he's grabbing on to
the plane the plane just takes off and
he's just dangling there
I love seems like that and they're great
for trailers I hope it's not the coolest
scene in the movie cuz when I see it in
the movie I'm really other coolest scene
they showed in the trailer that's always
a bummer but like that just basic
that that is James Bond in a bad way
we can only use more James Bond so the
trailer for Mission Impossible rogue
nation have you seen it what did you
think about it curious to know do you
think it looks - James Bondish are you
like yeah it does but that's cool too
whatever you think comment below let me
know and just letting you guys know it's
a busy week for me I'm gonna go to
Chicago for a couple days and then when
I come back immediately Emerald City
Comicon it literally is like bing bang
boom long story short I won't be able to
review get hard until about Monday so
you know if it feels like I'm not here
because I'm bouncing among two cities in
one week like ping pong and just as
crazy and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]